in the arizona desert linda rawls is a
thorn in the side
of president donald trump a white
suburban woman she belongs to the very
group that helped him win in 2016
but that is now abandoning him she can
look back at a life dedicated to the
republican party
she ran for congress in 1994 but her
assessment of trump
is devastating he has
become worse than we could have ever
imagined
no one really realized that he was
psychologically disturbed
i don't think people realized how much
he really would
not follow the constitution and how much
he would change the whole party from the
party of freedom
into a party that worships dictators
and destroys the rule of law
for decades arizona used to be a
republican stronghold
but it is now becoming a battleground
and the spread of the coronavirus is
playing a crucial role
at phoenix's largest testing site every
one in four
tests is coming back positive
voters in arizona are turning away from
trump for many reasons but one can be
found right here behind me at the south
mountain community college
it's an hour's long wait to get tested
here with the results coming in
a week after that at best and experts
say this is exactly where the united
states is failing
in stopping the spread of the virus
here on the outskirts of phoenix where
many voted trump in 2016
people are now frustrated at the
government's response to the pandemic
i certainly don't think he protected the
united states
taking measures that he needed to take
and
you know informing the american public
and giving guidance properly
so yeah he did a disservice to the
united states he has the power to make
it happen but
i'm seeing more other worried about
other things than than this what he
should be
i think they should have did this in
january yes
when they really knew but trump would
not
put it in action he said oh it'll just
go away no
it don't just vanish stuff like that
linda rawls still holds republican
values but she plans to vote democrat
this year
and she might not be the only one here
in arizona
well for more on the detailed political
picture in arizona i'm now joined from
phoenix by mike noble he's the chief of
research a managing partner of oh
predictive insights an opinion polling
company welcome to the day mike
arizona is traditionally a safe state
for a republican candidate
you've just published your latest poll
on the trump biden battle
what did you find well we found that in
when you said arizona is a tough hill to
climb for democrats
the last time a democrat carried arizona
in the presidential contest was actually
bill clinton
back in 1996. so arizona's been a very
reliable state
however right now trump is currently
down
five points to the challenger democrat
joe biden 49
for joe biden 44 for donald trump and
with very few undecided do we know
why voters there are deserting trump
100 so trump carried arizona back in the
2016 elections
by three and a half points what's
interesting about that
arizona's been a long republican state
as we've kind of discussed
and which compared to all the other
republicans that won
previously he won by the smallest margin
and so now we see we saw it in the 2018
midterm elections
what the shift was was among suburban
voters and specifically
among college educated whites uh that
ones that are higher educated
college-educated or higher voted uh are
turning against trump but also the ones
that it's trump's base are those that
don't have a
college education or high school or less
so those were the big shifts was these
suburban
demographics and independent uh voters
well in our report we heard from linda
rose that she's a lifelong republican uh
deserting him is there anything uh
trump's campaign can do
to win people like her back well i i
think they're gonna
they're stuck between a rock at a hard
place and i'll tell you why is that
remember arizona is home of
maverick john mccain he's a legend but
also he was a more
moderate republican in a sense but we
know before his
passing is that he definitely got in
some tips with donald trump trump said
some disparaging things about it
and so when you look at among moderate
republican voters
trump in the era of trump is essentially
started to alienate
that part of the base and so that is
it's not a surprise to hear that but
also knowing that
uh you you need to carry your voters if
you're going to hold the plan to win
on election day yeah but also you need
people actually to go
and vote any election depends on people
turning out
are people in arizona enthusiastic
well you know it's interesting you ask
that because when you look at the
enthusiasm the one advantage so
currently on
all the key uh variables in the key
numbers in the race
trump is not doing well however the one
bright spot for his campaign
was that he had about a 10 point
advantage over joe biden
in the enthusiasm category however with
covet hitting
recently that has squandered that
enthusiasm gap and they're essentially
they're tied so then there's the
coronavirus
pandemic which is starting to hit states
like arizona very hard right now
is the fire if the virus weren't there
would things be looking better for
donald trump
a hundred percent because arizona is
knows not only uh
is at the forefront of coronavirus
infections uh
you know uh it is definitely a hotbed
issue
currently here in the desert and with
the virus we've seen there's a direct
correlation among
elected officials whether it's our
governor or it's the president
when there are high spikes increases of
coronavirus
that that is a negative impact on those
elected officials
uh approval and with rampaging currently
here in arizona
you see that trump that has hurt him on
the handling
of the coronavirus mike noble from oah
predictive insights polling
in phoenix arizona thank you for this
insight
thank you so much for having me well if
only the virus wasn't there
but it is it very much is and no one
knows that better than our next
guest aliyah garcia is a so-called
traveling nurse that means she's flying
around the u.s on crisis assignments
to coronavirus hot spots currently
working in phoenix but she was
in new york when the city was hit by the
virus alia
in a previous interview you've said and
that's pretty much
impressed me i've seen a lot of death
how are you and your colleagues coping
at the moment
um you know we're doing the best we can
i think the number one thing is we know
that in order to beat this virus we all
have to work together as a team
work beyond the capability that we were
originally
trained for in this role and we're
supporting one another the best we can
you were caring for coronavirus patients
during some of the darkest hours that
new york has seen
how bad is it where you are now in
comparison
you know it's funny you ask because if
you would have asked me this just a few
weeks ago
i was feeling much more optimistic i
felt that
arizona learned from new york's mistakes
had enough staff had enough resources
but even in just the past few weeks
we are now running low on vents uh we're
understaffed
we're running low on rooms hospitals in
phoenix are having to transfer patients
i think even across state lines now
um so i'm starting to see a lot more
similarities and differences
at this point from phoenix and new york
it's a pretty dark picture that you're
painting there do you think it's going
to get worse there in arizona
i think it'll definitely get a lot worse
before it gets better at this point
have you been getting a sense of whether
people
feel they have been misled by president
trump what's sort of
the feeling on the ground there
um you know i feel like at the beginning
of this
coronavirus there were a lot of unknowns
um but the people that were in the best
position
to have truthful information were
licensed health professionals
and i think we should have turned to our
licensed health professionals in the
beginning trump included
um and maybe everyone would be at a much
better spot
and i think it's unfortunate that there
was so much conflicting information at
the beginning
because i think that kind of laid the
foundation
of wearing a mask and social distancing
now becoming a political debate when in
reality
it's a public health issue not a
political issue
well we heard in our report that people
are saying president trump
has failed in his duty to save and
protect the lives of american citizens
how widespread
is that view in arizona
you know i've only been here for three
weeks
so most of that time has been seen from
inside the walls of a hospital but i
will say there is a definite dramatic
culture change as far as social
distancing wearing the mask
i don't know if that's related to the
prevalence of people
loyal to the republican party down here
or not but
it is a stark difference from the sense
of community
of caring for one another that i've seen
in new york city
versus arizona and i think unfortunately
for a lot of americans
they're not going to face that hard
truth of the reality of coronavirus
until they or one of their loved ones
are the ones in the hospital bed or on a
ventilator
do you personally you've been at the
forefront of this fight against this
virus
do you feel that donald trump has done a
a good job
in handling this crisis
has he done um a good job you know to be
honest
i haven't followed that much but i think
the fact that
uh wearing a mask is now
turning into a political debate versus a
public health issue
is showing a major problem i think
americans should all come together
to understand that this disease process
does not discriminate if young old
rich poor republican democrat
it all affects us the same and
i don't know if it's necessarily helpful
at this point
to to point fingers of you know
who did what but i think definitely in
the beginning donald trump should have
looked to our licensed health
professionals
as far as guidance uh towards the
american people
how they should have protected
themselves and maybe we'd all be in a
much better spot
alia garcia traveling nurse in phoenix
arizona
thank you for finding the time for us on
the day
you